how many times you get one of the only
people in the world doing what you're
doing yeah
there's other people that tried it but
they haven't lasted
my name is art richie
and i'm one of the co-owners of carousel
works
and i'm dan jones and i'm the other
owner of carousel works
we're the largest manufacturer of wooden
carousels in the world
dart and i met through a third party
that we both knew
i went over to a shop one day and we
were talking and one thing led to
another and from there it just kind of
took off i was doing restoration he's
doing carvings we've had a 50-50
partnership for 30 years and there's no
very few partners just last over three
years so
you know it's not to say we haven't had
differences over the years and it was
like being married
but not that bad
we average
in different stages probably three
carousels a year
we're actually working on four right now
we have carousels all around the world
we made the cincinnati riverfront
carousel we have one in the bronx zoo we
have one the kansas city zoo the
nashville zoo the atlanta zoo the
riverbank zoo we even made the
smithsonian national zoo character
carousels will put people in the eye of
the child oh they're absolutely
beautiful
when you watch people ride a carousel
the kids are just loving to go up and
down and with these big smiles
and then the ride comes to stop can we
go again
it's fantastic
you